[Musique]
non
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro 17 8 culture 13 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actualité culturelle
sur notre territoire voici le sommaire
les portraits qui révèle le temps passé
ou encore l'empathie bienveillante
l'artiste associé à la commanderie dan
ramène exposé hors les murs au prisme à
elancourt une exposition intitulée média
mot la présentation du nouvel orchestre
symphonique de paris et saint germain en
laye les musiciens donneront bientôt une
série de concerts pour faire découvrir
au public le grand répertoire classique
kery james rose ou encore zazie leur
point commun ils seront tous en concert
à saint quentin en yvelines
plus de détails à la fin de ce numéro
dans votre rendez vous ce soir on saura
sky la nouvelle exposition de l'artiste
dan ramène est à découvrir en ce moment
aux prises mahé long cours el may hamm
au je m'appelle en espagnol est une
galerie de portraits saisis lors de son
dernier voyage à querétaro au mexique
[Musique]
aller à la rencontre de l'autre au delà
de la barrière de la langue
dan ramène photographe spécialisé dans
les portraits le corps humain à explorer
la ville de querétaro au mexique pendant
un mois
un voyage qui a donné lieu à may hamm au
une exposition visible aux prises maëlan
coup on est invités oui avec avec dan ah
non pas forcément découvrir la vie de
querétaro puisque c'est pas forcément
l'objet de l'exposition mais plutôt à
rentrer en contact à être avec l'autre à
découvrir toutes ces personnes en
résidence depuis deux ans sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
dan ramène a choisi de mettre en avant
27 photographies en noir et blanc des
personnes présentées dans leur contexte
de vie ou dans leurs contextes de
travail
ce n'est pas une photographie
instantanée où il parle de momentanée
dans la mesure où il a passé pas mal de
temps à discuter avec les gens leur
parle très peu espagnol
donc il avait un petit panneau pour
indiqué sa démarche artistique
et puis avec des petits bouts des ongles
et des petits gestes etc
l'exposition est complétée par deux
diaporamas en noir et blanc et en
couleur une sorte de huf à cette session
d'exploration
un projet à présent celui de la
compagnie de théâtre 7 septembre elle
recherche des habitants des communes de
saint quentin en yvelines pour dire
écrire et raconter leur ville
deux représentations auront lieu les 8
et 9 janvier 2021
une réunion aura lieu mercredi 25 mars à
19 heures au musée de la ville à
montigny le bretonneux
j'habite c'est un projet que je mène sur
plusieurs villes et plus spécifiquement
sur les villes de saint quentin en
yvelines
j'ai déjà fait j'habite à vélizy
j'habite à trappes j'habite à magny les
hameaux
et donc là j'ai un gros projet je suis
en train d'écrire le spectacle qui va
s'appeler j'habite saint quentin en
yvelines j'habite hashtag saint quentin
en yvelines
ce spectacle donc va parler des douze
communes de saint quentin en yvelines et
l'idée c'est de faire témoigner les
habitants sur leur ressenti par rapport
à leur ville
je collecte tous ses écrits donc là je
suis en phase d'écriture ses écrits ses
interviews alors filmé ou audio et je
les réunis et j'en fais un spectacle qui
va me les habitants et comédiens
professionnels et notez qu'il est tout à
fait possible de témoigner anonymement
et si vous ne pouvez pas vous déplacer
le 25 mars il est possible également
d'envoyer votre témoignage par mail on
reste au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui
accueillera du 14 au 21 mars prochain la
quatrième édition des rencontres et
insiter le thème cette année est la
ville de demain et ses défis lionel
masse et à le directeur de
l'établissement nous en dit plus les
années précédentes on a travaillé sur la
question du temps on a travaillé sur les
questions de l'humain demain l'année
dernière on avait travaillé sur les
questions de l'alimentation la
production la distribution et la
consommation
et là on va travailler sur l' on va
travailler on va
voilà on va se pencher sur la question
de la ville leur commande de la ville
oui la ville la ville et ses défis la
ville d'aujourd'hui la ville de demain
donc une dizaine de tables rondes
douzaine une quinzaine de
représentations avec trois spectacles et
puis une dizaine de films à l'ugc
quatrième édition aussi pour le festival
électro chic à versailles grand parc
ce sera du 12 au 14 mars au programme
des concerts dans plusieurs villes
versailles vélizy ou encore fondées
fleuries et des têtes d'affiché mais
aussi des jeunes pousses de l'électro
qui participeront un tremplin le 14 mars
[Musique]
vous êtes chanteur chanteuse musiciens
musiciennes et vous souhaitez devenir la
star de la fête de la musique en juin
prochain à plaisir et bien c'est
possible vous pouvez envoyer votre bande
démo et un descriptif de votre groupe à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran vous avez jusqu'au 15 mai notez
que la fête de la musique se déroulera à
dans la caserne des pompiers est
découverte à présent d'un orchestre l'
orchestre symphonique de paris et saint
germain en laye il vient de se créer
donneras une dizaine de concerts en 2020
dans les yvelines et dans la capitale
reportage
[Musique]
tout part du constat que les yvelinois
vont généralement à paris pour écouter
de la musique classique
mathieu arnaud décide alors de produire
de la musique localement et font de
l'orchestré de paris et saint germain en
laye l'ensemble des enfants de
l'orchestré symphonique tous les
instruments à cordes violon alto
violoncelle contrebasse tous les
instruments à vent notre première série
néanmoins sera en plus petit orchestre
pour y développer progressivement celui
ci
matic de blondel vie depuis ses 4 ans
une histoire d'amour avec son
violoncelle en décembre à décide de
rejoindre l'orchestré symphonique c'est
très agréable de pouvoir se projeter
aussi sur un peu plus sur la longueur
sur ce genre de chose quand on vous
appelle juste pour une série c'est vrai
que il ya une date c'est après on passe
à autre chose laisse aussi créer
d'autres relations avec les musiciens
avec l'ensemble la musique haussier et
c'est vrai que ce qui est très agréable
dans cet ensemble ce qu'il ya vraiment
une histoire sociale emballé par le
projet le chef d'orchestre félix mathus
et chaises a de suite accepté de
rejoindre le groupe
les thèmes de la joie et de l'humour
seront principalement abordé au
programme est prévu la plaisanterie
musicale de mozart la symphonie numéro
45 de hayden ou encore le célèbre
beethoven il veut tout acte et il n'y a
pas des traditions qui est pas d
d'habitude
donc c'est qui va intéresser surtout
c'est ça et les sérieux du projet d'un
projet de biens bâtis
c'est très important et je le constate
chaque fois que tout est correspond un
grand sérieux une grande solidité une
poubelle
vision d'avenir au total une dizaine de
représentations sont prévues en 2020 le
29 mars prochain l'orchestré viennois se
produira dans l'église de saint germain
en laye à 15 je vous emmène à présent au
théâtre de la barbacane
ah ben il a récemment reçu à la visite
de la députée yvelinoise aurore bergé
dans le cadre de son rapport sur la
culture pour tous
l'établissement mène plusieurs actions
culturelles tout au long de l'année
notamment des représentations théâtrales
ouverte aux scolaires
reportage la troupe de la pièce en train
muros saluée par les scolaires après une
représentation uniquement dédié à ce
public venu du centre yvelines ah ben
le théâtre la barbacane et géré par un
syndicat intercommunal sept communes
sont associées et travaillent ensemble
sur la programmation
la spécificité de ce bâtiment c'est
qu'il a été construit et ouvert il ya
une trentaine d'années avec l'idée que
tout le monde allait pouvoir se croiser
et une bibliothèque municipale un volet
associatif qui est porté par la ville de
ben avec différentes activités de la
pratique artistique
et puis dans notre salle de spectacle en
effet il ya spectacle mais aussi cinéma
plusieurs fois dans l'année les
représentations théâtrales sont suivis
de bord plateau un moyen de partager qui
permettent aux scolaires de se
familiariser avec le monde du spectacle
j'aime bien la transmettre un petit
savoir l'autre chose partager un peu
avec avec les jeunes parce que moi dans
mon parcours personnel j'ai souvent
rencontré des professeurs que ce soit de
sport de lettres de même de maths ou de
géographie qui m'ont souvent apporter
autre chose que leur matière en décembre
dernier l'établissement culturel a reçu
la visite d'horreur bergé la députée
yvelinois s'est inspiré de ce lieu pour
son rapport sur le développement de la
culture pour tous donc l'enjeu c'était
parler de comment à l'échelle d'un
territoire
on arrive à créer des mutualisations des
convergences des circulations qui
viennent parfois jusqu'à notre lieu
théâtre mais parfois c'est le théâtre
qui va sur sur les villes du syndicat un
accompagnement à la culture qui a
également permis à la barbacane de
devenir le premier lieu des yvelines à
porter le label scène conventionnée pour
la musique ce sera la 100e édition la
foire internationale de chatons se
déroulera du 13 au 22 mars sur l'île des
impressionnistes
il s'agit de la plus grande brocante de
france l'occasion pour les chineurs de
dénicher des trésors et des produits du
terroir seront également présents pour
les plus gourmands aller retour à saint
quentin en yvelines avec plusieurs
spectacles qui vous attend ces prochains
jours
le rappeur kery james ce sera en concert
acoustique au théâtre de saint quentin
en yvelines à la batterie de guyancourt
la chanteuse rose présentera les titres
de son dernier album kérosène l asie à
sera sur la scène du prise miles en
cours avec son 10e album essentiel enfin
de la danse avec les pokemon crew
ils seront à la merise attrape voici un
avant-goût de ce qui vous attend
rien n'est moins sûr pour l'instant
suivant
il n'y a que des futurs morts parmi les
vivants et vu que demain n'est qu'une
hypothèse
tous nos projets devraient s'est créé
entre parenthèses que d'arrogance dans
nos attitudes
pourtant nous n'avons aucune certitude
[Musique]
ce qui doit arriver mais jamais le matin
la mort est notre destin de plus
certains
le coeur qu'il faut quand
quand ces gars le diamant
ça change de chansons
[Musique]
et prend fois comme pour la première
fois
l'odeur
[Musique]
le chaos rings
et par aucun
[Musique]
ça
tous ont pris que sékou sow tout
marchesseault
c'est
humour
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
une émission d'ailleurs consacré en
grande partie au printemps des poètes à
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]